[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you know
yo yo yo
what's going on guys
yes
my beer is gone
well your beard man
it's in the trash
so let's let's get the jokes out out of
the way Chad I know you guys are going
to be joking that's fine
it's perfectly acceptable you know the
suck will be back
here soon
soccer
there's feedback all right is that
better is there feedback now
is there feedback now
still hear it
I don't hear feedback hold up
let's just close out of all of this
all right what about now oh there's a
buzzing in the background hold up
it's probably my AC is a meat yet it
could be my AC hold on let me mute let's
see if it's me
so there's he's muted
now here here's me music
who did it disappear from
it was definitely yeah you just got to
it is out it might be this headset
because I'm charging it
no
nice headset man that's a nice game that
that headset represents yeah I can't
wait to play it I can't wait to play it
yeah
like
self-conscious about me without a beard
man
it's all right man hey the jokes are out
of love brother
well I don't like them
all right all right so let's get into
this let's get into this we got we got a
pretty pretty crazy show for you guys
man there's been a lot of stuff going on
I might have a special guest showing up
you know I don't know if they're going
to be here but we might have a special
guest showing up
bro
that's fine I'm perfectly fine
uh you know I don't know if that's uh
they saying all white people look alike
is that what they say is that what they
say
I feel I feel discriminated against a
little bit I ain't called a lady and he
will lie to you
all right so
welcome to the attic show where we talk
about the past person future game I got
my co-host with me Dirk griggity what's
going on dirt what you've been playing
oh man
uh you know what
I've been playing Call of Duty games
I've uh I don't know you know by me
being such a bot and you know this this
deal this you know even though it's
prolonged a little bit
um but it's still still in my opinion
it's going to close soon I've been
playing these old Call of Duty campaigns
I never finished I just finished
infinite Warfare it was a pretty good
game not as good as some of the other
ones so that's pretty much what I've
been playing man I'm just pretty much
waiting for Starfield to be honest with
you I don't want to even start any other
you know big games I just I'm just
waiting for stocks for y'all
actually I could talk about the second
game I'm playing I'm playing Starfield
I'm playing sea of stars okay so they uh
both so the sea stars review go up on my
my personal Channel
and we're gonna have special
coverage for Starfield on iop's channel
so definitely be uh checking out for
that guys
oh my God these people man
attic forced to shave his beard during
an only fan session you guys are
ridiculous yo shout out to uh we did get
a a member before the show officially
started
uh it was Craig gifted one of you lucky
suckers A Gifted gimmick milk uh a
member chat we want definitely want to
appreciate that so let's get on this
it's got a lot of talk about today you
know first off let's let's go into the
summer I don't even want to talk about
but we got to okay
okay
actually let's talk about Forza there's
been a lot more force of stuff going on
uh so I feel like that's something that
we talk about have you seen any of this
gameplay on Forza at Gamescom yeah yeah
my stuff on Twitter what's your opinion
on you think it looks like that that Gap
that kind of most of us expected
um I wouldn't say it's like a huge gap
because as far as the motives were
already looked incredible like the last
one from 2017 uh which was uh was it
seven yeah like seven look dope but I
think it looks good you know what I'm
saying um still would like to see the
game in person but I think it looks
pretty good I wouldn't say it's a huge
leap
but part 7 looked incredible on Xbox One
X anyway so
yeah so
let me see now it's
I don't know why
I don't know why people care that all
right anyway so I'm not the biggest like
racing person but the game looks pretty
detailed
like this is the one if I were if I if
if I've been told correctly because I
don't play Racers that's more of like
that hardcore
Racing type of thing like they they
stick to more of a hardcore audience
I hope I got rid of the the sound guys I
got rid of the headset
so it's gonna be interesting man
yeah I think so because you know like
you said I'm not as big into the
simulated racers
as I am with like Horizon I love Horizon
series uh you know back in the day is a
little burnout series I'm more of an art
arcade racing fan I'm not really into
the Sims but look bro turn 10 is a
quality studio so I'm expecting the game
to be quality they have five years so
you know we'll see what happens but I
think the game looks great like I said
I'm gonna say it was a huge
um jump but then again I haven't seen it
with my own four eyes so
up close on my television so it's all
good what's up everybody in the chat I
was listening for that sound
wolf said your beard is missing like the
Bluetooth from PlayStation portal
my mic is no longer hooked up hold up
all right maybe that will get rid of it
I doubt it but maybe that I can't hear
it I'm like maybe because I'm on the
show with you I can't hear what they're
talking about
anyone chances it might be a second mate
I don't know what second mic it could be
the only mic hooked up let me mute again
and make sure it's not me I'm about to
mute
was it still on there you guys like you
know what they said is you sounds like a
fan let me turn my air off
no not not anybody to be up here
sweating y'all see what y'all did he
about to be in his sweating
um about to sweat for like the next
hour but it's kind of fun all right so
let's talk about this APK deal yeah
because let me really a lot to talk
about when it comes before is that I'm
just not the biggest Forza fan but I
understand that people love that
franchise absolutely absolutely you know
there's some guys like like fuzzy
Belvedere loves those Sim races man he
loves Gran Turismo he loves Forza
Motorsports so I know he's hyped for it
bro but yeah there's some people that
love the franchise
I like the franchise you know like I
said I'm more of a horizon guy but yeah
it's pretty dope
all right keep talking I'm gonna reset
my microphone
they said it's not the AC
foreign
I can hear you
what about now guys what about now
that could be better
they said it stopped okay yeah they said
it stopped yeah whatever that noise was
you fixed it
worst
oh nice oh they say still the oh now
they said it's still there damn
I can't let me press mute because I
can't hear what they're saying I mean
what they're hearing
it's the market
s oh yeah it was gone because I turned
off my mic obviously
well I'm gonna try one more thing and if
that
yeah they said it only stops when adding
mutes
what I'll have to do is I have to keep
muting when I'm not talking
all right so
sounds like white noise I don't know I
don't know what it could be I think this
has happened once before uh
is it too at least go home and they can
live with it you know all right so all
right let's let's talk about this this
APK though so apparently Microsoft's
willing to pretty much make a deal with
the Devil yeah they they um
they're willing to to to throw away
their cloud
distribution
for ABK deals and give it to Ubisoft in
order for this to go through
what do you think of that because that's
that's something crazy
that that's
something I never expected what do you
think of that
yeah
um I think they're doing what they have
to do because you know obviously they
can they could close over the CMA but I
don't think they want to do that because
they are still going to have future
acquisitions
and they want you know you know they
don't want to be on a CMA bad side
obviously so um I think they're doing
what they have to do because the CMA
obviously they blocked it because of
cloud concerns so they're like okay fine
you guys have Cloud concerns we're gonna
do uh like whatever we're gonna do with
Ubisoft give the cloud right I don't
know I don't know all these terms or
whatever but pretty much Ubisoft is
going to step in and they're going to
distribute the cloud
um so and like Phil expensive mentioned
on the interview today is strictly cloud
is not native Xbox game pass though so
activism blizzard games will
um through the cloud will be with
Ubisoft or distribute through Ubisoft
help me out if I'm wrong guys because I
don't be paying attention like that I
just want the damn deal to be done
that's what I want
yeah I understand I just have to keep
muting my uh mic when when I'm not
talking that way you guys don't hear it
I think it's interesting that they that
they chose Ubisoft like
um you
you send them work together
like I would be more
if it was like EA or something because
they had because you've seen a
relationship with them
yeah that is weird that Ubisoft um I
guess maybe they I don't know man I
guess Ubisoft offered what they needed
and Xbox is just trying to get the deal
done Microsoft has to say and um you
know Phil Spencer mentioned it's not
strict bro it's more about Cloud than
anything with this APK deal I'm sorry
let me take that back it's about mobile
more than anything with this APK deal
and that's the biggest Focus so they
have to distribute
um their Cloud streaming through Ubisoft
so be it they're trying to get this deal
closed and they feel that this should
you know that the CMA should
um approve it they if they're confident
they're going to prove it because you
know they threw out the old the the
um they throughout
what Microsoft proposed in the past
they threw that out like what the CMA
actually blocked they threw that out
now here's a new proposal and now we
gotta wait to see if they're going to
prove this who the hell you know should
have taken forever
yeah so I guess to me when it comes to
this like I'm already seeing the people
talk about
the Microsoft's fine Ubisoft that this
is the this is the groundation for them
to buy Ubisoft like I feel like at this
point we we getting we getting too crazy
no they're definitely not bad
um I don't know if the Xbox one to go
through this whole process again
but um yeah but I mean it it's just
gonna take longer most of us thought it
would be the cma's decision will come
this week or next week but obviously the
only thing that happened was Xbox new
proposal Microsoft new proposal and
we'll see what happened next brother
I still think it's I definitely think
it's going to go through though
because if their their concerns were
Cloud Xbox has a brand new proposal on
the table that's listen they're not
going to distribute how Ubisoft is on
ABK game so
all right I turned it I don't know
what's going on with my mic but it's
it's it's crazy uh I might go ahead just
for this podcast it might the quality
might be worse but I'ma just switch to
uh the headset I currently have now
because clearly something's going on and
I could sit here and fight with it all
day
they fixed it they say it's fixed now
oh my God
say you good now man don't touch it's
fixed okay okay okay
yeah all right all right so so it's five
because I ain't gonna keep talking I'm
gonna see people in the chat saying it's
not fixed so that's fixed brother
all right all right because I turned
down the uh the game like a lot
not fixed just lowered it's great you
good okay all right so
let's talk about and I apologize for
that guys it's it's mad unprofessional
but sometimes stuff just happens uh
I wish
I wish this thing would just end yeah me
too bro
it's like I feel like every every couple
days like
do you think because I I saw a hole
posted on Twitter he said that he thinks
they are
that it's possible
that they are going to
the they're trying to do this to get the
deal thrown out like in the long term
like delay it
um
bam that's interesting I didn't think
about that I didn't even see that tweet
from Hogue um no I mean I don't know man
who the hell knows there but it's it's
kind of weird to me though attic when 40
Regulators say yes with no concessions
then all of a sudden this one regulator
is like trying to block it I mean I
don't know man that just seems weird to
me
that seems weird to me
yeah I feel you man and you know to me
it's just like I'm just on this point
where I just like I want to talk about
games and shout out to you guys because
I made
an update on Starfield
and you guys showed up on my personal
Channel let me let me explain you how I
want my channel to run
I want my channel to be on a three-prong
rotation
I want to cover the news of that game
cover the game
and then uh cover the news to the
platform cover the news to the games
that of the platform and review that
game when it comes out that's what I
want my
my try my my little my little tried and
Spear of content that's what I want and
for for a long time I've made I made
updates on a vowed
um
about updates on Fable now the Fable
videos do relatively well
um
but is that a vowed one
and it got like 300 views it like
demoralized me from trying another like
loud dude about I made a video updating
a vowel content and it just it didn't do
that good it didn't do that good so that
kind of put me in this like mindset
where I didn't want to really try to do
too many updates on games
so when the when the Starfield stuff
come out I was like okay let's do it
let's try this again and I and I did and
you guys showed up like you guys showed
up a lot I think it's at like four or
five thousand views
and you'll start feeling yeah something
like that five five yep yeah and I have
a custom wrap yeah yeah
well no it was the one before that oh oh
it was the one before the custom rifle
so it was three thousand
okay yeah I'm making so much content I'm
getting myself confused on this stuff
yeah 3600
um uh and I appreciate that because that
that's what I that's what I want man I
want to be able to talk about the game
bit early for about I get you and that's
why I said I think it's one of those
things where I have to just go how how
it flows
uh you know I think we've gotten to the
point now where first off let's give
let's give a
a shout out to the Xbox Community you
know you can say what you want about the
Xbox Community you know sometimes
you know we might be a little messy
but every event I see every event
we got some of us representing us there
you know guys was just at Gaz uh
wandering Dutch like all of them are at
Gamescom right now
what you guys gotta stop stop talking
smack about my beardless face okay no
one asked for that energy
yeah they're going crazy on my beer
they they said attic what I had to kill
my boy but why you wanna rock that booty
face
she said put them up
my girl said she put them up addict your
Blackness that interview was lit
blackness
I I think they are you mean dirt because
I'm like
the the I I literally can't be any
further being black
like I'm pale okay
uh oh you talking about the Peter Moore
yeah you know first off don't give me if
you talk about the Peter Moore don't
give me credit for that of you that that
was all call caulk stayed up for two
days
reviewing
researching or research researching he
that that interview was very important
to him because like Peter Moore is like
Kings Phil Spencer yeah you know I
actually
told Carl I was like
let's use our our connects and let's try
to get us let's save for the Stars
try to get us a uh a Todd Howard
interview
you know probably not going to happen
but you know it is what it is we got a
uh member chat member chat from Joey for
16 months 15 months Lord Peter Griffin
now people are calling me Peter Griffin
in the chat
calling me Peter oh man addict is Batman
Okay I I hear that one I hear that one
addict has a job interview that's not
entirely false that's not entirely false
oh see let's see yeah and then plus you
know because I because I've been like
getting like ingrown hairs a lot and
it's just my mother the skin under my
beard was getting like really rough and
I needed it to like really do good by
like treating my skin
so that's another reason I shaved
all right so let's
too much information oh you know you
guys sitting here talking all kinds of
smack imma imma tell you guys
all right so let's let's get on to this
uh Xbox series X reps
first off
they look nice
yeah they look nice which one did you
like the most
I like to start field one the most
um
the camouflage looks fine but I like to
start feeling one of the most that's you
know that's probably what I would get
I'm going to get I should say
Starfield
yep yeah they at first
it didn't look like it would fit very
well
like if you look at it it looks weird
how you wrap it around but then when you
look at that video
it looks a lot better like I will yeah
it looks a lot better oh God two dollars
from Karen's raisin potato salad
is that a thing in the black community
do you make fun of white people from
from making raisins on potato salad
I have no idea I've never heard of that
uh getting that
dcj that oh man
why you guys doing me this way
oh my God I'ma call you a Karen how
about that I'm gonna call you okay got a
ten dollar from JD gamer I think Dirk
Gregory is Right Microsoft has more
Acquisitions in the pipeline so they
don't want to go afoul on the CMA
question is who does the panel think
Microsoft is acquiring that Sega Square
absolute I think it I think if that
third one they don't need all this extra
stuff you know what I'm saying
how bad you think the internet would be
if they bought Sega I mean not Sega
Square Enix if we just woke up one
Tuesday morning and we see that famous
Square Enix all their games and it's a
square the little x
uh Xbox I think that will be man
um the Meltdown that happened in January
2022 with Square Enix
I'm sorry with uh activism blizzard was
huge but I think Square Enix being so
close to Sony
and Xbox purchase them that would be oh
man that would be crazy oh look a little
doggy
but I'ma say I don't think they're gonna
get another publisher anytime soon I
think they're going to go out their
Studios and I truly feel the first two
is Crystal Dynamics and Idols Montreal
first two yep because they're already
doing Xbox games
I'm kind of curious your opinion on if
they do buy them do you think that they
remain their own independent Studio
because I feel like if they buy those
Studios from embrace your group they're
merging those Studios but the studios
they're working with I don't absolutely
I don't think they're going to be
individual Studios I think they're going
to become one team with multiple one
studio with multiple teams that's that's
definitely possible I think Crystal
Dynamics now mere Crystal Dynamics has
two teams right now one's doing Tomb
Raider one's of course doing Perfect
Dark with the initiative I do believe
Crystal Dynamics will maybe merge into
the initiative or I don't know they keep
the same name as Crystal Dynamics and
the initiative name goes somewhere but I
do agree with that now Otto's Montreal
though
um you know what I think you know what I
think you got a good point because Idols
Montreal they are great Studio but they
are working with playground and Fable is
going to be a theme moving forward they
already have their Horizon team so yeah
I actually kind of agree with it imagine
this Crystal D that's what king likes to
call them Crystal the in the initiative
marginal one team they they make Tomb
Raider uh they make um
and then they start the next iteration
and re-brand Tomb Raider again
reboot it against yeah reboot it and
then Fable they finish Fable and they
make another uh Dex X
after fable
because I feel like both of these
Studios can work together very well
but I will say this though if so so
you're saying that Idols Montreal will
merge the playground or will they merge
with if they merge a playground I think
they're going to be playing around bro I
think they're no no they they're not
going to take their names they're gonna
murder the studios are just gonna merge
together it's not gonna be the original
name Crystal initiative that would be a
good name like I'm not gonna lie I
actually feel like
the people who made Fable uh playground
game should have been renamed to lion
head Studio well yeah I think I think
that name had uh you know a catch to it
I I get it it's too late now they've had
it for a certain amount of time there's
actually an interview where Phil Spencer
said he regrets shutting that studio
down yeah yeah yeah they said that on
that um documentary they did
um Idols Dynamics I don't know but
that's a good question we obviously
don't know this is like these are just
predictions but I do feel that those are
the first two Studios they go after
maybe even iron Galaxy if Xbox is happy
with I think the way killing stink is
going I think they buy a year year and a
half from now
Galaxy will be Microsoft Studio
absolutely
they're happy with the way uh like
healing thing is going they're not gonna
risk
losing the ability because even if they
don't intend on doing nothing with
Killer Instinct they're not gonna risk
not having Killer Instinct in their yard
no absolutely all right so we got some
super chats coming in let me grab these
okay ten dollar super trap from JD gamer
panel please list the
the probable Acquisitions in order they
will be purchased and how you think they
will be integrated and what game you
want to see them uh uh see from them the
most after they finish their current
games
um
did he give us games to to do or is he
no no no like he's just saying um
oh probably the the studios that he gave
us earlier yeah and he said what uh yeah
so you know I I said Crystal Dynamics
and Idols Montreal and he say uh
how do you think they will be integrated
well you know like we just said because
attic Fields they're going to be
integrated with the studios they're
currently working with I tend to agree
um but
I'm not 100 on that boat I but I I think
Crystal Dynamics
is more likely to merge with the
initiative the idols Montreal is with
playground games that's just my opinion
um but now after the current game
I didn't care for the last days asked
for whatever reason
um
I would like Auto's Montreal to make a
new IP personally
because I'm gonna tell you I'm I'm gonna
tell you why because one Guardians of
the Galaxy was incredible two
some people hate it shadow of the Tomb
Raider for some reason
I thought it was just as good as rise of
the Tomb Raider and the Tomb Raider
reboot from 2013 I thought it was
incredible
so I would like for them to make a new
IP but I do want Crystal Dynamics you
know to work on Perfect Dark Tomb Raider
I think those two games and and sequels
would be dope for me
yeah I get I hear what you say I think
to me
out of all students who would you want
them to buy the most like I want them if
I say Square Enix and or Sega I don't
know why Morris a publisher yeah more
score Enix is I want to see the world
burn
it's coming I wish I could just live one
day of that announcement being true um
now from a console war standpoint I
would you like to see them buy screens
because that would be a crazy day bro
that would be cool you know the content
that day will be lit um
imagine like the Alex type of contents
because he's gonna have he's gonna have
content for days
days upon days upon days
oh it's going to be magnificent see but
me personally I wouldn't
score me persons by Square Enix doesn't
do anything for me
the only content I like from Square Enix
they already sold
which was their Western Studios so
squares would do nothing for me that's
what kitsu says he prefers he doesn't
really care about squarings I think you
know Sega would be a really good look
um you know when it comes to you know I
was I was thinking you know be crazy in
a couple years
uh Microsoft is a is exposed that they
that they've actually been embraced the
group this whole time
like it's like a it's like a shell
company
[Laughter]
funded by Microsoft oh man I mean
obviously the chances of that happen is
zero but imagine how crazy that would be
like the legal actions like oh my gosh
it's just like who's that Pokemon
Microsoft that would be crazy
uh yeah uh yeah hold on like Kevin
Baldwin yeah we know they're owned by
embracer right now yeah they are
technically but
we see embracers having Financial issues
and they're trying to sell off so what
better story listen they're already
working on Xbox games
Xbox dropper bag They're Gonna Roll with
Xbox bro just imagine like having a big
meeting oh okay like you said he was he
oh I'm sorry like he said he was telling
Michael okay I'm sorry bro because I I
know I know Kevin Baldwin the homie I
know you know this information thanks
bro imagine like they're having a
meeting
and they're like anyone that that works
for Crystal D will you please go home
and then like the crystal D people get
it like oh no no no about that
why are you guys getting up well we're
going back up no you are ours
right if you ever see the skit that me
and King did about the the crystal D and
and the initiative takeover
no I didn't actually it was we were
saying that like they had shirts on that
says Crystal D and the initiative was
being kicked out by the crystal D
workers
hey Addie let me ask you a question
because Lord Metroid says Amazon owns
the Tomb Raider IP not embracer listen
correct me if I'm wrong but I thought
am uh what embracer did was
license the right for a TV show and
they're the publisher of the next Tomb
Raider video game I don't think they
sold the IP to Amazon
I vaguely remember something about them
selling it to them
who owns
Tomb Raider now
I thought they license the IP tone uh
Crystal Dynamic officially owns Tomb
Raider again so that was when all that
happened that was 2022.
and
yeah I thought they licensed the IP to
him yeah so I I don't think they sold it
to him does Amazon own Tomb Raider the
Tomb Raider franchise including the
video games cheaper rights versus are
owned by Amazon
uh say that again embracer the Tomb
Raider franchise including its video
games TV rights films merchandise and
it's like its own uh uh and it's in the
likeness is owned by Amazon now
embrace your group will no longer with
uh withhold the rights after it acquired
from its uh recent buyouts the deal was
included for 600 million which makes it
the okay so pretty much they bought that
and they sold it to Amazon
oh okay so they did sell the Tomb Raider
right yeah I remember vaguely hearing
about that but you know
I'm pretty sure if Microsoft wanted to
and they did do something like that
because that would be a a key component
I mean maybe that's not a game that they
could do maybe if you're thinking about
tomb Raiders ran its course maybe it's
time to move on
all right so thanks we'll see let's get
on because there ain't really much talk
about the Xbox series x-ray uh wraps we
we kind of went on like like a little
I don't even know what we would consider
that to be honest with you
all right so what we're going to talk
about all right so I'm not going to talk
a lot in this one I'm like you talking
this one
starfish okay all right
what is your expectations with Starfield
and give me a Metacritic score
assumption that you have
um
well I would say this do you see the
buzz surrounding this game bro
yeah I mentioned this last week the last
game I saw with this much Buzz was maybe
Elder ring
yeah that's what I'm saying and that was
after the game release you're right I
didn't read the buzz about like
surrounding that game was after the game
released it's crazy man because
you know two weeks ago people were
saying it wasn't being marketed now all
you seeing is Starfield stuff you
mentioned you just thank the people for
tuning in to your Starfield video bro
my channel grew
um pretty big from June to July
or something around that July dog
something because I was talking about
Starfield I did a video about Dreamcast
got hating on Starfield
and it we know it was right after
actually June right after the Xbox game
Showcase in the Starfield Direct
bro people was interested in Starfield
the the direct impressed people so much
they were searching Starfield content
and a lot of people found my video
is my biggest video ever and it's like
wow so the bugs with Starfield it's
crazy right now bro like you just said
you you know you got 5K or some like on
the on the custom raps about Starfall
you know you sit here you're spitting
bars and they want to see the kittens
like look my girl's in there feeding
them unless you want me just to rip them
away from being fed because that's the
reason I missed last week like my girl
found a cat and some kittens and when
she took them home the cat just
abandoned them
uh so she's uh we've been having to
uh you know to to nurse them too well
there can actually eat on their own and
um my girl's in there right now feeding
them
oh okay
yes yeah um
about my matter prediction is 92.
I'm gonna say 91 92. all right there
okay I am going to say that now as far
as like
as far as the Starfield thing
it is crazy the amount of people that is
trying to [__] on this game
like
I'm getting a headache just thinking
about it because there's so much
information like
first it was the game is it hasn't went
gold
then it was you fake outrage on whether
they're not when the review code went
out then it was
okay uh you know it I there was
something else
I can't remember what it was but there
has been multiple incidences the title
screen that's what it was thank you Josh
the title screen the title oh my God
this has been the most ridiculous moment
shout outs over the 450 people in the
chat right now hit that like button guys
let's get that above 200. I know I know
like 70 of you ain't like this I know
you ain't did it that's okay sometimes I
gotta remind you is a like button just
down here yeah hold up no no
unfortunately
no it's it's like right here the the
like button's like right here actually
right here right here no right here
but I appreciate y'all you know
definitely hitting that like button I
just don't understand why people are
going above and beyond to hate on this
you know why
you know why Addie
you know why people going above and
beyond hate it just say it just say at
it because it's an XBox exclusive thank
you Addy
[Laughter]
I feel you on that I feel you yeah
I just yeah man title screen oh that was
terrible bro that title screen was the
worst oh yeah look homeboy got me title
screen no demo lack of marketing XBox
exclusive
yep thank you Game Shark
yeah bro we've been talking about it
it's been stupid man it's stupid
no demo no dip oh I forgot about the no
demo when the guy was saying it's not
going to be a Gamescom a demo was not
going to be against Conquest I don't
know if you saw things they really
talked a lot about Starfield today
all right let me get this uh 20 uh 200 I
don't know what currency that's uh
that's that's the end that's Japanese
yeah oh that's what's up I I that's
that's awesome from spoon that's the
homie Sony love man I love when I see
people support this community around the
world you know what I'm saying it gives
me like uh attic looks like John
Letterman's little brother
oh my god oh come on man five dollars
like JD gamer Legacy of Kane Soul reap
uh Reaver
uh a proper Tomb Raider a proper
exclusive Tomb Raider
these are my dreams what classic IP do
you think we'll see from them uh I would
actually be really okay with uh Legacy
at Kane I think even though I don't play
that a whole lot I I really see why a
lot of people love that I don't know I'd
like to see a um a Dragoon
I'd like to see that we got a member
chat for four months from Sofa King
y'all need to watch to see if Microsoft
pulls the trigger on on Disney legally
it is possible Mike if Microsoft bought
once if Microsoft bought Disney now I
know the odds of this is like very very
slim
and then they just ripped off the
PlayStations no you got Spider-Man 2. we
got Spiderman three four Wolverine now
we working on that like five dollar
subscribe for the angry therapy they mad
they can't get in the club but they can
just buy an Xbox or play on PC or tablet
I know you are under uh NDA but maybe
you could answer the question do you
know anyone who has been playing Star
foot on the Rogue Ally
uh
I don't know if I can like answer that
so I'm not I'm just I'm gonna say you
can't answer it guys yeah
live stream for with the kittens for for
now on attic uh they you guys are
ridiculous man you guys are ridiculous
all right let's let's get to the
let's get to the main event of the
evening
Phil Spencer I don't know how many of
you
are aware of what's going on okay
gamescom's on right now all right and
obviously what happens when there's a
games called dirt there's media there
there's media there and one of them our
own Dustin first off shout out to Dustin
because he actually asked Phil some
tough questions yeah he did yeah
um I'm loving seeing these Outlets hit
more hard knowing questions instead of
like there was another question
there was another outlet that did a Phil
Spencer interview and they didn't really
ask anything like Xbox on Xbox yeah it
was it like it wasn't that great so go
ahead I'm sorry to interrupt you didn't
really ask anything like crazy or
anything but tell me what you think if
someone's calling me I just see who it
is I thought it was great man Phil
Spencer is actually trending right now
guys
um let's be real man
there were two IGN uh like both phones
around 12 minutes long Destin interview
with Field Spencer he asked them about
the Xbox series s he asked them about
Xbox future about are you guys gonna
going to still do the four uh like the
four games a year meaning one game per
quarter he asked us some great questions
and feel didn't dodge any of it he asked
us some stuff about ABK ask him some
stuff about after the deal is closed
you know will ABK games go into Game
Pass immediately Phil said no not
immediately because there's still some
work
some technical work they have to do to
get all of those games in Game Pass but
they will be going into Game Pass that's
not as quick as people think they will
he has some great questions man um he
mentioned redfall
um for bringing up red fall and you know
what shout out to Phil Spencer because
it does anything I've noticed and I
appreciate with Phil he is the king of
taking accountability
he would like when they were talking
about whether or not they were going to
have that four games
from here going on Phil brought up 2022
and he could have easily yeah
easily left that out he didn't even need
to bring that up he's like look
it's been rough
2022 was not a fun day for anyone yep
but we got you now we got you a star
filled here soon like a month and a half
two months later you're gonna get Forza
and then probably three months later
you're going to get hellblade stalker
tools and just around the corner yeah
man like I said he's trending and you
know something else I love bro I know
we're all over the place with the field
um quotes
but remember when Destin asked I'm going
to read it verbatim what he said
Destin asked him said Game Pass is a
tough sell to a lot of execs Bobby Kodak
potech testified as a tough sell to
bring Cod to Game Pass after closing how
are you going to bridge that difference
Phil said well there's different people
making the decisions meaning Bobby
kotech ain't gonna have no say-so
anymore we're making the decisions and
look Phil answered this I'm going to
tell you how I feel like I'm
paraphrasing but Phil said Look Man
games like Call of Duty GTA 6 NBA 2K man
those games probably shouldn't be in
game pass because those sense yeah right
but I don't give them sale Millions
every year I don't want to go too much
in the successful stuff because I do
think there's different definitions of
success I think in that particular thing
he's saying these games are so
monumentally successful that going into
a subscription service would hurt that
tremendously uh that and then he brought
up he just got out of like a meeting
with bunch of heads of Indie developers
and they were saying that that was
keeping the lights on essentially now
obviously I'm paraphrasing but he was
saying that they were very grateful for
the opportunity to be able to work with
them in the game pass because they were
they would be able to keep the lights on
make new games you know people just see
the negatives that they want to see when
it comes to Game Pass look is Gamepad is
going to work for everyone of course not
I don't think anyone's ever said that
right well there are certain things that
doesn't work does Microsoft probably
foot the bill when it comes to marketing
stuff yes they do uh do they get that
back I would say they do get a lot of
that back but they are right now in the
planning a strategic phase where they
don't expect to see like huge profits
between now and probably the next five
ten years because that's just how
corporations do things they don't do the
short run they do the long Sprint
yep I I agree with you brother I agree
wholeheartedly but yeah uh check out
those interviews with Destiny there's
two different videos like I said they're
both around 10 to 12 minutes long and I
thought he has some he had some great
questions man um you know but like you
said he did bring up 2022 and he did
bring up redfall and I think those
things you know should be brought up
what happened in 2022 Phil said we
didn't deliver in 2022. the only thing I
didn't like like 100 is I didn't like
how
he it's not that Phil tried to like
avoid the conversation but when they
were talking about redfall he was just
like you know because of our
relationship with Bethesda software
Studios it was easy to work with that
studio and I get that to a point but
there is like you own this company now
and you got to make sure they have the
the necessary tools and the support so
it that's where I do feel like the the
cause and effect system needs to be
better the the we need to see what
you're doing like I think there needs to
be like a scale obviously I don't know
how they would do it but it's like look
if you frequently delivered good games
for us you frequently done well we might
check on you every six months you know
what I'm saying we might check on you
every year if you do really really good
work
but if if you've been like a little bit
sketchy Rocky we're gonna be over there
every three months maybe even every
month
uh and I think that you know the Arcane
thing was just probably too much and I
don't know how you feel dirt I think
maybe the Arcane was them focusing
focusing so much on Starfield
they're like we've got to make sure
Starfield comes out it's as bug free as
possible because even Matt booty said
six seven months ago if they were to
release Darfield now it would at that
time already
bethesda's least buggy game ever made
yeah I believe they I do agree with what
you said I do think they they really
want to focus on Starfield because it
was going to obviously be a bigger game
the red fault but Phil Spencer admitted
that they learn they learned some stuff
you know they kind of just trusted
Arcane Austin because they had a pretty
good track record of quality games even
though the games didn't sell great for
Arcane Austin or Arcane period
their games were always quality so they
kind of trusted them do your game we're
going to focus on Starfield because it's
you know it's a BG s game and um
and also let me say it's right quick
before you go Phil did mention which we
always say
being the first party
different Professor being under Xbox
being the first party games it comes
with a lot more scrutiny than if they
were still multi-platform
yeah and I feel like he's being very
open with that you know one of the
things that they need to work on is
establishing that because I think
regardless how we feel about PlayStation
they make the same style games over and
over again for the most part there's
outliners like Spider-Man I don't think
that's their average type of you know
over-the-shoulder action adventure game
but for the most part when PlayStation
delivers a game and they announce a game
a lot of the consumer base automatically
have positive outlook on how that game
is going to be delivered because
PlayStation for the most part have
better quality control now Phil clearly
admitted here you know this is something
that we need to work on he even said
that he thinks redfall
didn't go through those policies as well
as they should have because of the
pandemic you know he said they they
bought
they when they bought Bethesda like it
was like a week later they told everyone
to work from home and what I like is he
didn't use that as an excuse he just
explained the situation explain the
scenario explain what the the variables
that led to the outcome but said at the
end of the day that was our stuff I
can't use this excuse I just want you to
know what happened
yep yes he did he did bro
all right
was going to get these super chats real
quick
all right Zack Snyder wants to do a make
a Gears of War movie I'll be down for
that oh really
yeah that's what he said the games come
oh that's what peel up with the two
dollar Superstar dirt you should give me
some of that Microsoft money if I
remember where we are well funded
20 super trap from JD gamer they're
doing their jobs when they're not just
asking Xbox executives are hard
questions
they're doing their jobs when they're
not oh okay okay
but when they're asking these uh the say
these questions uh PS Executives that's
when they're doing a good job and they
need to be held accountable as
journalists okay I'm kind of confused on
what he's meaning and let me read this
again they're doing their jobs when
they're not just asking Xbox Executives
the hard questions but when they're
asking these
these same I I saying questions they say
questions of PS Executives that's when
they're doing a good job and they need
to be held accountable as journalists
okay just to clarify Jed are you saying
that they need to be held accountable on
all fronts even if they're talking to
Executives on PlayStation and Xbox or do
you think that they stay away from these
questions they talk about PlayStation so
we need to help we need to hold them
accountable even when they talk to
PlayStation is that what you mean
all right let me read these super chats
while you're answering that five dollars
chat from Corey Tidwell Phil try uh
Phil's tired of talking about redfall
the game should have been canned it's
just not a good game move on and forget
about it oh yeah but at the same time
he's gonna have to talk about it
regardless it came out of his camp and
it's good because
it's a blemish so
you know that's like you know like a
sports team they have
a great record but they have that one
terrible loss right well they lost about
30 points and people gonna ask them
about it
and I think it was just how bad the the
game came out and was delivered I think
that's what made it even worse is you
know even if you
don't like like pinnamon pinnamon ran
well and it was perceived good for the
people that did play it yeah it was like
86 or 85 or something redfall just
didn't run that great it it had a lot of
bugs it felt empty in a lot of areas
when I played the game I felt like it
had a severe case of identity crisis
where I didn't know what it wanted to be
didn't want to be a looter shoot they
want to be a first person didn't want to
be like that traditional Arcane type of
style and I think when you put all those
together is the reason that redfall was
in the position it wasn't when it did
come out
yes Troy Brown I would say uh saying it
is unfinished is definitely a fair
statement
yeah and but no I still feel the game
has so much potential I finished it
um there's a lot I liked about the game
but you know like I always say it was
arcane's best effort but um you know
it's it's you know their action feel
about it but you know what's gonna
happen they're going to stop asking them
about it because it's gonna they're
gonna have so much more positive
um content on Xbox they're not going to
ask them about it anymore but you know
still right now they're asking about it
and he's not dodging the question man
he's not dodging it
respect to him
question what are you doing next
Thursday is that when you do your solo
podcast or is that yes okay yeah I
usually do it every Thursday at six
Eastern okay
because part of me is like man
don't really want to have a show
Wednesday when the day before the
embargoes lift I mean you would do it
well my soul starts at six you want to
try to do a five o'clock we can kind of
how can we just do it on your Channel
I mean we won't have the attic show next
week we'll do it on your channel yeah I
mean we can
do yeah what next week there will be no
attic show we're going to see then I
like dirt to run stuff for an afternoon
so yeah it's cool so next week Thursday
me and dirt sometime uh 6 p.m uh that's
what he says that exactly 6 p.m Eastern
yep we we will be doing you know a star
feel and you know what since I'll pretty
much have a Beat by that 10th time just
ask me anything you want yeah yeah we
can talk about it then
that'd be dope I like that yeah that
sounds good
it'll be a one-man dark man with with
someone else because you know I call it
one-man dark man dark man and light man
podcast
he'll be mashed potatoes and gravey
Oreo podcast
[Laughter]
yeah funny stuff I actually don't like
that because that means there's another
black entity yeah yeah I don't know
about the earlier one yeah let's not do
that one
all right so you know normally I like to
to wait around and you know raid uh
raid fames podcast but day and night
podcast I like that that's a good show
that's a good one man that's a good one
day and night podcast
I'm looking forward to this oh yeah it
would be a good show you know uh
definitely the Starfield Alec can tell
me exactly because I you know I will be
playing it on the 31st but I have to
work and I won't have much time to play
it but after the show but I can ask
addict everything he can answer whatever
you want to by that time so
yeah and plus you know we uh the attic
DP
K what
I'm done with you guys
I'm done
come on man I'm done that's it all right
but I appreciate it for coming through
here you know I don't know if we could
send you guys to anyone because
unfortunately Fame isn't live yet and I
just I don't have the mental capacity
like I'll be real with you guys
sometimes if it's like five ten minutes
before fame I just blamber uh like like
ran about something and most of the time
I don't have to do it too much but there
ain't really much to talk about today
you know there's stuff to talk about
just not anything that I really want to
talk about yeah uh game on uh I don't
know how to pronounce this dude's name
it's the dude that does one has his
podcast Asus or
I think that's ASA ASA came on Acer I
think that's him I don't know I'm gonna
send you guys over to him tell him attic
show sent you attic show sent you dirt
five dollar super trap from Lord Star
Killer what's up brother prepped and
ready for starford Early Access check
Starfield headset check hold up hold up
start for the headset check Starfield
controller check starford pre-wrapped
order I I don't I don't know oh
pre-order
I don't need a pre-order I already got
it two hours I got the wrap already no
no I actually I I ain't gonna lie I I
did I was like
I said someone over there like I need
that two dollar super trap from
game shark oh check there you go tell us
search up for game Black Thunder white
light
oh they're gonna keep up with these
names for us all week man all week but
yes remember next week Thursday at 6 00
p.m we'll be going on in the Black
Thunder White Lightning podcast with
dirt and me and Dirk's gonna ask me
questions
baby next Thursday the Metacritic will
be out by then so we can let me put my
link in the chat man for those that's
that's not subscribed I'm almost at 11k
man I'm like three away from 11k I'm
going to do a video after this show
today shortly talking about uh you know
there's been some PlayStation guys in
the community that kind of had a change
of Hearts regarding Starfield all of a
sudden they're interested in Starfield
um yeah so um I'm gonna do that and of
course I have my dark man tomorrow and
next week we have the one we added we're
going to be discussing Starfield or
white light yeah I like that the ebony
and irony because I actually think
that's an actual podcast oh yeah it
might be yeah I think that's an actual
podcast but anyway definitely go in
there check that out we'll see you guys
next week and until next time this
gaming addict and dirt
he's out y'all
ebony knife
that's funny